all right i think we are ready to start
um we'll be starting on time um
so welcome everybody we'll give i'll be
giving a talk introducing you to
um the new geometry functionality of
mathematica 10. and first half i'm going
to try to give you the whole picture of
how all fits together the flows and the
workflows and then
the last half we do some exploration
where we use it a little bit more
and there's several more talks in this
conference that covers various aspects
of it
so the big picture
of what's happening the things that are
in geometry
is regions that have many ways to create
regions
um they can use numbers parameters
formulas
even graphics and and other things or or
geometry defined in various
file formats and so on to create regions
from regions there are various things
that we compute properties you know like
area and
volume and distances and stuff and
there's a whole slew of solvers
but to just keep this sort of simple my
you know picture in mind
and we'll get through this pretty easily
if you break it down a little bit more
we have four kinds of uh
of regions we have basic regions or
special regions these are things like
ball
and disc and line and and so on
we have something we call formula
regions these are things that are
defined by formulas
like implicit conditions that set up a
region
or parametric formulas that define a
region
then we have a mesh based regions and
they're two basic types they're
they're complete sort of full detailed
mesh regions
and there's what's called boundary mesh
representation where you give a
like a polygon where you give a boundary
curve or a boundary surface
and then there's something else which is
called derived regions which use which
are built from other regions so
like a boolean combination of things is
an example of a derived region of
transforming a region and there's
lots of them different kinds there are
four kinds of
properties dimension stuff is very
important for determining
many things with regions membership
moments moments is things like area
and centroid distances and then there's
a five different kinds of solvers
visualization solvers integration
solvers optimization solvers
equation solvers and pde solvers
that operate on reaches
okay so let's start the tour so a region
is simply a point set of rn so all of
our regions are embedded in some space
rn and in mathematica concretely
anything that's region q
is a region
so basic regions are simple and common
specified with a few parameters like
ball
formula regions formulas here's a simple
example
they're really flexible but they get
kind of complicated too
but they're exact and you can get exact
results
a mesh based regions are very flexible
particularly sort of as a ways of
approximating regions
um they're specified with points and
cells
here's a typical region here's a volume
region where you have a collection of
of volume cells in this case tetrahedra
these can be in any dimension you know
they can be
line curves in in 3d and so on they they
don't have to be full dimensional
derived regions they're very flexible
and allows you to sort of derive
derive new ones for molds so like a
union
okay so let's look at some examples so
here are some basic regions or special
regions
so geometry works perfectly well in 1d
in which case we have point line and
interval
2d we've we've effectively doubled so
almost all the things that are graphics
primitives before are now also geometry
special or basic geometric regions but
beyond that we've doubled the number of
such primitives
in 2d and 3d and so there are there are
now
unbounded regions like a half line or an
infinite line
there are other things that are more
sort of high schoolish which is you know
side side side triangle
those kinds of things and
and so on likewise in 3d you have some
of the same things but you have you know
half plane infinite plane there are
new unbounded ones and you have various
cells like parallel pipette and
hexahedra prisms and so on and very
general things like conic holes
and a lot of these special regions work
perfectly well in any dimension in
n-dimensional space
it's it's kind of silly to restrict
yourself to 3d and mathematica it's just
or just full dimensional 3d it just
looks
arbitrary and silly you know
although it's very very important case
so don't get me wrong you know
it's just um
okay so let's run through some i forgot
to delete the outputs here so you're
gonna see it
you know here's an implicit region um
and
and you see that there are two types one
is that we give a condition
you guys that i've been using mathematic
and using region plot and other things
have gotten used to this and if you
integrate using bool
with conditions you've gotten used to
this and you you probably already well
warmed up
this is a way to represent it as a
region and to be able to compute with it
as a geometric object very cleanly and
combined with everything else
parametric region just what you think
it's kind of like parametric plot
it has one more case you know which you
can give a condition here like a p
condition for your parameter space for
those folks who come from the cad
industry these would be called trimmed
regions
where you give conditions on the
parameter space
um and here is kind of like a hello
world
case like being can you integrate over
it and so that's just
doing that to show it's it's it's a real
region so this also indicates another
thing that
i want to integrate over region this is
a 2d region this is a symbolic vector
variable and says like you know
x is in that region and just integrate
over it
3d one
hello world case again and um
so that is implicit or formula based
regions
now mesh based regions um they are i'm
going to sort of show
two things here one is that the mesh
based region
is basically a disjoint union of cells
and so
the case that you probably all
intuitively have in mind is like a
triangulated surface
that's a really good case so that's a
disjoint union of triangles
but they can be any kind of of piecewise
linear cells
and they can be in any dimension so a
curve with line segments in 3d is a
perfectly good mesh region
so
the other one which is boundary mesh
regen they can
they're a little bit more compact
they're like polygon you only represent
the boundary
mesh for it so in in 1d
it's two points in 2d it's a curve and
in 3d it's a closed and oriented surface
that you have to specify to give those
and in
works perfectly well in nd2 not for us
right now but
the theory it will generalize
okay so here's an example for those of
you who have used graphics complex you
can see this is the same idea
that the the coordinates the geometric
embedding is separated so these are the
points
and these are indexes into the points so
the first triangle here
includes points one two and three index
one two three and the next one three two
one
and this is you know for those of you
who are used to graph
we can put properties on individual
cells that make up
a uh one of these regions and so and i
can also use them as labels in here
so here is a collection of two triangles
the hello world test here's a collection
of two tetrahedra
so here's the points and down here is
the
multitetrahedron tetra801 is 0.1235 and
so on
here's a well apart from the hello world
test
the boundary mesh region so i have a
bunch of points
um and i can specify one boundary
and another boundary i can specify
arbitrarily many boundaries so these
guys can have holes
the way what house determined what's
inside of a region
is called the ray test so if you put
yourself at the point
and you draw a ray out to infinity any
direction you want
if the number of times you cross one of
these boundary surfaces
is odd the point is a member of the set
if it's even it's not so if i put myself
in here
and i put a rate infinity i cross two
boundaries it's an even number
so i'm not in that very same idea works
in in any dimension
so here's a case of 3d where we have a
hole inside
so at two surfaces there's an outer
surface and an inner surface
and the test for membership is exactly
the same rate test you draw a ray to
infinity
and you count the number of time you
cross the surface so if i put myself in
the middle here and i draw a ray to
infinity
i cross two surfaces and even numbers
i'm not in hence it's a whole
a void okay there are other kinds of
holes that naturally come up they're
usually called tunnels just
because there's this distinction right
you have tunnels and voids in 3d
and you know some what do you mean by
hole do you mean a tunnel
does a donut have a hole in it or a
tunnel
or a void or anyways
this is a pretty complicated way to
build them but it's still very powerful
to be able to do that
so most of the time you're going to use
other kinds of constructors to build
these mesh regions
you can build a dalani
triangulation it's called dylani mesh so
it uses
a you know it builds up this collection
of simplexes the simplex is the
generalization of
triangle or interval to any dimension
and
this one builds up the collection of
those
voronoi which we'll see a little bit
later
builds a you know each for each point
that you give here it will give you the
cell
that is of set of points that are closer
to that point than to any other point in
the set
okay it's really an infinite region so
there's another argument that you can
say which region you want to look at it
and you know mesh regions can only
represent bounded regions
convex whole mesh is um
is effectively the the outer surface of
that delaney triangulation
and it is a convex set so you know
surprisingly guys
um now another thing is that one way
that we can build up mesh region is to
discretize graphics
so graphics contain both piecewise
linear primitives that can be
represented exactly
and non-linear primitives like disk and
ball and cone and so on and these guys
need to be discretized to a certain
resolution
there's also many other useful utilities
in these guys that allow you to filter
out
say how finely you want to discretize
now so i told this guy to build a
boundary
mesh region and so that will if i have a
big graphic scene with lots of things
with lines
and sometimes things are diagrammatic
you don't really want that to be
geometry because it was just
like an arrow to illustrate something i
mean we can integrate over that arrow
too but it's
often you don't want to it was just an
illustration
so this one that one would fish out all
the full dimensional things
because that's the only thing that can
be represented with b reps or boundary
representations
now if we triangulate we can fill out
the interior by triangulating it
and this is making use of what's called
the constrained delani triangulation
we can get there's a lot of functions
that won't show about
ability to drill down into meshes but we
have other talks later in this
conference that we'll go into those much
more
and this gives you the number of points
lines and triangles
so the number of cells of different
dimensions zero one two
if we have a dis here's a more
complicated implicit region
around that
we we can see how that um that
comes out and so these implicit regions
can be quite complicated
in you know the ability to describe
fairly complicated sets
um you can just this highlight graph and
other kinds of functions we have a
highlight mesh that allows you to style
and um and illustrate and and and so on
in this case i style i
tell it to style all the one-dimensional
cells
that are in there and i want them to be
red so that means all the line
boundaries
final type of region is is a derived
region and this is
one thing that you will see grow a lot
over the coming releases in mathematica
um in wolfram language so there's
boolean operations
union intersection difference symmetric
difference symmetric difference is
basically like an xor
of regions you know the things that are
in
in one or the other but not both or
a general boolean function you can see
that all the you know all of these
boolean operations are effectively
defined by boolean
conditions or you can do it for any
boolean function
and we have a lot of them in mathematica
product is cartesian product
transformations by a a mapping
or the inverse of that the inverse image
or the boundary of a region
okay so let's do some some simple
examples here
there's a bunch of disks and so here are
you know the four
most common boolean operations union in
section difference symmetric difference
um let's look at some transformations
so here's a variety of affine
transformations and you know there's a
huge library of affine and linear
fractional transformations that you can
do in mathematica is a pretty rich set
and
we'll be enriching that too
so this is what that one does
so right now um it's it's sort of
restricted to affirm transformations for
these mesh regions that will be
uh relaxed as we go forward for the
other kinds of regions you can do any
any kind of transformation you want
okay so properties now
um so a property is is something that
computes it's like
a statistic if you like if you think of
probability and statistics what's the
mean what's the variance
what's you know some kind of property so
every one of our regions they live in
some space
and you've seen me showing mostly 2d and
3d
and so they live in 2d or 3d but they
can live in in any
d the region itself has a dimension
and the dimension is determined by sort
of the
the largest dimension a ball that you
can put
inside of it so um
a curve you can basically put a little
interval ball if you like
on it so that's a 1d thing and
and and so on that has some implications
for
for for instance how we integrate so if
you tell
in 2d to integrate over a curve it will
use a curve integral
it uses that dimension information to
determine what to do
so we have membership properties this a
search membership
and this test membership and give
conditions for membership
with a lot of things there are special
names for 1d 2d
you know 3d but generally speaking you
know we can be nad
including 0d centroid gives a measure of
what a center is of a region
it's one of many possible you know
centers
nearest distance and sine distance the
nearest point
from a point to a region and what that
distance is so let's look at some
examples
okay so here are some some low
dimensional examples so here is the um
here is the along the um x-axis here
this is the
the dimension along the y-axis is the
embedding dimension
so here's a point in 2d here's a point
in 3d it's still
a zero-dimensional object here is a
curve in one in 2d
and one in 3d it's still a
one-dimensional object
here's a surface in 2d and 3d
it's a two-dimensional object and here's
a volume in 3d
it's a three-dimensional object and i
could have extended it because we we do
support
1d embeddings too you know 1d regions
are perfectly good
one the embedded regions okay so here
are some concrete examples um just
the um a disc as we know is
is a 2d thing a circle which is the
boundary of that disc
is i'm sorry they're all embedded in in
2d
the circle lives specifically in 2d our
circle does
and and the point and this one that has
four dimensional
sort of coordinates it lives in 40. okay
but but the actual dimensions are
the disc is 2d the circle which is the
boundary of that disk is a curve so it's
1d
and the point of course is you know a 0d
object
now we use element or we
typically use the typesetting notation
element of
to assert that a point is in a region
like so now i can use that and we'll see
that shortly
as a way to to specify that i want to
integrate over that region
and this one had some parameters in it
so the result has some parameters in it
if i want to test for membership or i
get conditions from membership i can use
that you know any of the regions that
we've seen
four types and i give
symbolic parameters here i can get the
actual condition
and you can see that in this case we
also get in fact the condition on the
parameter
coming out that's an assumption the disk
assumes that we have positive radii in
this guy
disks okay now
if i give if i do the same region member
without a second argument
then i will get a region member function
that can then be applied to points and
it's very useful when you want to test
membership many many times
so it gives the same result as if i
had given the point in that original
function but it
provides this more efficient way this
more efficient representation that can
be used so here's an example
where i generate a region which is a
convex hole
and i generate a hundred thousand points
and also
just instead of generating that region
member function if i give a long list it
will apply it will first build that
function
that region member function then apply
it in parallel
in a listable way to all of these this
this last extension
comes with 1002 um in ten zero zero
it uh it's sort of a two-step process
and then i
can visualize these uh 100 000 points
green for the ones that are in the
region and red for the ones that are
outside of the region
okay so what about moment properties um
um or um or integration oriented
properties
so we have special names that we all
grew up with like length
area volume and but more generally we
have
a measure function and so the measure
function
will compute the
the sort of the generalization of volume
to first of all points and what the
generalization there means counts
that's the appropriate measure for 0d
objects
and the generalization for volume for 4d
5d and so on
so it will look at your region and says
what's the maximal dimension that that
is the dimension of your region
and then it will use the corresponding
definition
centroid integrates sort of
the the moment and divides by the by the
measure okay so here are some examples
if you and the area of a circle is 2 pi
the
the arc length of some implicit thing
and here we can see it's an ellipse
it computes if you give exact input it
tries to give exact outputs
if i had approximation on the inside it
would use approximate methods
but if i use exact input you know you
get the real
real true thing this is a perfectly good
curve for us
it's very much not manifold for those
who cares about that
i found that most things in the world
are not manifold so
the area of a disc these are things that
we all know are
that's a boundary mesh region the volume
of a ball we know
um volume of a of some mesh region
but here's an example of a sort of a
convenience the n
if i give an integer argument to sphere
it will give me the n
dimensional unit sphere so these are the
volumes
sorry the measure which is the areas
of the n-dimensional spheres
up to dimension 10. i can use some other
functions in mathematica that we had for
a while
that looks like a sequence so maybe i
can identify what the general formula is
from that
and um in this case find sequence
functions is able to find it
but this this this was simple and we
know that and you you can look that up
but you can use that for many more
general things and it it
actually works surprisingly well
okay so the centroid thing gives you a
sense of where the center is of a region
so as we know the center of a disc is
just the middle point that we use to
specify it in in mathematica
um we can do center centroids for for
anything
now in this case i give the polygon that
i gave here is not convex and one thing
that can happen
that you should be aware of is that
centroid doesn't necessarily
lie in the region unless it's convex
um but again you know these mesh regions
they
they they display themselves but they're
still regions
and so i can just use that as an
argument into any function that works
with geometry
and um this is the center bunny
okay it's just more fun with cows and
bunnies
than than than discs you know and we can
sort of leave spherical cows
um okay region nearest
so if i have um if i have a point and a
region what's the nearest point in the
region to that point
and what's the distance to that nearest
point and then something that's slightly
more subtle which is the sign distance
and if that's a point outside of the
region then it's the same as distance
if it's a full dimensional region let's
say a disk
then that's the distance to the
complement to that disk
so it's the distance to the boundary and
it's negative
when it's inside and so it gives you a
different name different domains have
different names for these things
sometimes it's called the depth
of a point that negative
okay so again um
you know if you give these symbolic
arguments to it like we saw from member
will give you actually a closed form for
it
now these can be pretty complicated um
except for a disk and ball and so on
here is for instance for a triangle
and you know even that got sort of
surprisingly
complicated but they're very fast as you
know we spent a lot of time deriving
these
the again if i don't give a second
argument
it will give you a nearest function
something that you can compute
if you want to do this a lot will
provide an optimized form and the ones
that you can see what that optimized
form would be when we have formulas but
for mesh region it's not formula it's a
procedure
so if i apply that to a bunch of them it
it will give me the nearest point for
each and every one
okay so distance as we said is the
distance to that nearest point
and it works pretty much the same way if
i don't give a second argument it will
give me a distance function
apply that in this case and i can plot
these iso distance curves
from the triangle so the triangle sits
here in the middle somewhere and i'm at
distance .25.5
one or i can do the same in 3d
should be pretty fast
and the stylesheet has some weirdness
and so
so now we come to so that's properties
there's a few more
but those are the most important ones um
now solvers is one thing that makes it a
lot of richness
to use geometry and it gives a lot of
enhancements and enrichments to the
solvers themselves
the one important thing that um that we
finished but we didn't document for
10.00 but it will be part of 10.02
that we're about to drop is to be able
to plot over regions you still
saw examples of us doing it in in the
literature but it was sort of more
select examples
and for 10.02 it will work really well
so i kind of have stylized versions here
so you can plot a function and you just
indicate
where you know where you want that
variable to lie what region
same idea works for integration symbolic
and numeric integration
over region same idea
we can solve pdes and there was a great
talk yesterday and there will be another
there will be a workshop on it this
afternoon and so on
we can solve pdes over regions
and we can even solve with you know
maintaining parameters in that pde and
do sensitivity and other things
we can optimize over region this is a
little bit more general than it seems
here because i can have any number of
extra region
constraints like this in my constraint
list but i wanted it to look similar so
this this is the way it looks i can
optimize over a region
and i can solve equations and
inequalities over regions
so that alone so here's about 30
different solvers that now
today work on regions
okay so here are some examples of of
plotting so i give a bunch of intervals
here
um that's that's what it comes out to
and who said that the sine function
wasn't monotone
i mean it it's the you know depending on
what domain of definition you use right
so um or i plot sort of a function over
a disk or uh
i can do these vector plots like stream
plot over a disc and so on it works with
any region any of the things that you've
seen me
show okay
likewise we already seen a lot of
examples of integrate because i've been
using it sort of as a hello world thing
one thing to remember though is this
what what i said like in the case here
where i give it this is a
this this circle lives in 2d but it's a
curve
and what integrate will do it will do a
curve
integral in this case so if i integrate
one over a curve
it will give me the the measure of it
indicate this case the
the length if i integrate over a disk it
will do a 2d integral
if i integrate over a ball a 3d integral
and so on
this is again a perfectly good curve to
us
very much not manifold
and this is the length of it this is
actually looks like a volume you can't
tell the difference between surfaces and
and volumes this one is the surface um
so this is the
the surface area of that cow this is a
volume
and we'll see more of this this guy a
little bit later it has tunnels going in
each
in every direction that is integration
pde is i'm not doing it justice here at
all but we had a talk yesterday we'll
have a
workshop this afternoon we we we we you
know and i i know you guys are really
interested in it
and so if i solve this is a poisson
equation
i give some um very kind of basic
dirichlet conditions i want it to be
zero at the boundary you can see that
here in the plot
and then i just solve it over a disk so
i can now plot it over a disk
which we just learned i do the previous
talk john talked about pdf import
well we can we can import the outlines
of fonts
and that's a perfectly good mesh region
or boundary mesh region so i did that
and there it is and now i can solve the
same equation
effectively over over wolfram and so
here's the poisson
equation solved over wolfram
i tweaked the right hand side to get
them to droop the right amount
okay we can optimize
over regions or with region constraints
so here's one of these
18 optimization functions
i want to just minim i want to find a
minimizing point
for that over a disk and there it is
i can't find a maximizing point and if
we show that
um i think that this is useful first
time you start with
teaching optimization to show the level
curves and this is the
minimum and as the maximum attained at
the boundary
these things get very easy to explain
now whether it's just class or just a
report or something
take two other regions and i want to
find the minimum distance between these
two regions
so i have one point being region one the
other one in region two
what is the minimum distance and one
thing that you see me use here
is these symbolic vector variables so
notice i didn't do all the components
here these are 2d regions
and what i get out is the the results
the two points
or i can find the maximum distance and
here is a visualization of that
so that's the two minimum the minimum
distance points and the maximum distance
points
uh last group of solvers are equation
and inequality solvers
so let's say that i want to find the
intersection between two lines
so here is line one line two and just
find me the x's and y's that they cross
it and here's a visualization of that
or a line in a circle
in this case i switch over to use these
vector symbolic vector variables
and there are those and that's an
illustration of that or i want to find
the intersection of three spheres so i
do
is my three spheres and i want to find a
point that's in all of them
that turns out to be two of them the way
i place the spheres
like so
okay so here's what we've done you know
you now
know everything okay this is the whole
thing this
is the story this is this is it okay so
just to to recap where we're at
you know there are regions and we sort
of four kinds of regions
four kinds of properties although they
have many more actual concrete
properties
and five kinds of solvers
and there are many concrete solvers like
30 of them
so now i wanted to switch over to sort
of use it a little bit
because i wanted to get to this point as
fast as possible
because you kind of need all of it you
know
um and this one i want to illustrate in
the second part
so here's a let's let's let's study a
topic you know what the
what is this thing called house door of
distance between regions
okay so the house dwarf distance is
defined
as you know it needs to be symmetric so
it's max of two things
and this thing here is called the
directed hausdorff distance from a
region a to region b
and it's given you know it's given
basically as i'm going to minimize
the distance between points where i pick
one in a and i'm going to take the
maximum of that
so i'm going to illustrate and compute
with the functionality that we have
so let's do it let's let's try to
understand this concept
with just two regions uh two triangles
this is the way they look
so the red one is a the blue one is b
now
i wanna first of all the innermost thing
here is the minimum right
well that's exactly sort of region
distance
so let's use region distance that's that
inner infimum here
now let's let's just stop a little bit
and plot it okay
so remember what we do now we plot um
for all the points in b
which is all the blue points so we plot
the minimum distance from all the points
in b
to the set the red set and when i
overlap
of course it's going to be zero right
because there's one point right under it
and here they're outside and and where
we use the ability to plot over regions
and you can see that when i'm sticking
out
it's going you know more than zero
so now we use the fact that we can
optimize over regions
so we compute the max value
and we've computed that directed house
of distance which turns out to be a half
and which now we built the intuition we
could probably have guessed that it's
kind of that half up there right
so fine um you know one thing that we do
know if the directed hauster of distance
is some number
epsilon is that we know that
that set that second set is included
in a slightly enlarged version of a in
fact it's enlarged exactly by epsilon
the distance epsilon
so here's the visual of that so we know
that this blue triangle
is included in if i just enlarge that
red set
the red region by by a half
distance a half it's included
so fine then we can compute it the other
way around so we get the other directed
distance which turned out to be a little
bit bigger
um and now we can compute the house of
distance so this is
just using sort of a first round of
using the functionality to do something
kind of easy to illustrate and easy to
understand
okay so here's another sort of just
relatively you know simple
straightforward so we we want to define
a a i'm going to define eventually as a
mesh region but first as an interval
canter set so counterset is defined
you're starting with the
zero one interval and then you keep on
removing the middle third of the set
that you have left
and this is what i'm saying here you
know so if i have this region i'm just
going to
take that's the first middle for the
first third and the last third
and i skip the middle one fine we can
define that easily enough in just using
mathematica programming
just apply my rules and so here's you
know i start with
the 0 1 interval then i remove the
middle third
and if i plot a few of them it looks
like this
so this is using a new function in 10
number line plot
okay um great um what's the you know
what's the length of these
these you know step and cantor sets well
i can just ask for region measure i
could have
called arc length which is the same
thing in this case
and i get the sequence of numbers and
let's guess
at what that is and then we say oh i'm
stupid i could have just
guessed that right away probably but
that's
a good way to build intuition and
realize that you're stupid you didn't
realize
you know you know you check it
okay but so let's just generalize it a
bit
you know and so there's some you know
someone came up with this
of course it's like well why don't we
take cartesian products and we get
what's called canter dust instead so
fine we have
canter region so just let's take the
product
and we get canter dust okay so this is
what they look like
this is k here's what step in that
counter construction
and this is the dimension so in 2d if we
do that for steps one two three this is
what they look so yeah
i removed the middle third and then took
the cartesian product
and then i remove the middle third again
and so on and so on
and here's what it looks like in 3d
these are all perfectly good regions
there's nothing wrong with them now
we could play that same trick that we
did for intervals
and we'll realize we're stupid again but
it's you know it's okay
so we we compute the the measure of it
so the areas
um want to have rational numbers for
this guy and let's guess it
and we see that this is effectively sort
of that two-thirds squared right
the four-ninth you know
in every dimension or we could play the
same trick in 3d
and compute it again and apart from the
fact that it flips it
upside down it's you know two but two
times two times two
divided by three times three times three
at cave and with you know since we're
playing like let's just generalize it a
little bit and take why don't we just
why do we have to have the same step
canter because visually these are kind
of interesting right
so if i do um the cartesian product of
canter
region in step two or step three and
step one you get sort of you know
get whole families of these um
interesting um
you know creature roids
okay so let's use again
the the the functionality that we have
to construct
another region and this is something
called seidel's polyhedron
um i just saw a picture of it and said
we got to construct that
that looks really interesting so the
idea is this thing has tunnels that go
in every which direction
and they never cross okay
so we're going to use the tools we have
to build this up
and so one thing that the way you know
one
way there's met probably many many ways
to do this like no idea but
but one way to do it is to think of it
as just just like a rubik's cube kind of
filled with
uh with uh cuboids right and we're gonna
preserve some cuboids and we're
to we're going to just remove some
cuboids for the tunnels
so that's the idea i'm going on that
means we can use grids and arrays to
generate this whole pattern
and then finally we have sort of a mesh
region at the end
one little thing that we need along the
way is to be able to
figure out what's the position in a sort
of a in this case a 3d array
um when we flatten it and if i flatten a
3d array
position this position i1 i2 i3
and if i dimension d1 d2 d3 will
transform into this
new position okay that's how flattened
works
and you kind of just work that out so
this is what this function index flatten
actually computes
and so if i index flatten this this just
gives me that formula back that we saw
and so if i do here is an array
it's dimension 2 3 4. if i pick out
the part number 132 i get that guy
if i first flatten it
if i first flatten it and then i use my
my flattened index position
i get the same thing this is what i
wanted it's just a little utility okay
now i can just generate a giant table
here of grid position so that's my kind
of random embedding of it
and then the hexahedron which i want to
use
to build up the cells in the mesh region
has this particular ordering of vertices
so i need to abide by that when i
package them up as hexahedra
so i do that this routine
and now i have something that's actually
much more general than for a seidel
uh polyhedron i have something that can
work for any volume mesh
built out of cubes you know so if i want
to build a maze
out of cubes for instance i can do that
now but we're not we're doing the side
l1
okay so here i give it a 3d array
and so here is it's a you know great
i kind of i get a hole so
um we have other things that generate
these kinds of arrays right this is the
evolution of a 2d
cellular automata for some steps fine
that's a perfectly good mesh region now
that i can do things with
but a little bit of experimentation you
realize that this is the actual 3d array
that you want
for the inside l case so it's a period
is it basically periodic
um some kind of periodic function
i'm not going to go into it more but i'm
using this array grid mesh constructor
just thought about that right so then
here is the first simple case
and this looks promising this looks
kind of like that side l thing
and if we compute something else that i
showed you was one of the mesh
constructors i can represent any full
dimensional mesh region by just using
its boundary surface
so i compute that here and i adjust some
styling using highlight mesh because i
don't really want to see the edges
now for instance so no edges and i want
the
the 2d faces to be transparent and then
we get the result that we started
that you saw me there and if i push it a
little bit further and and so on
you get that so that's an example of
just using the toolkit that's there to
do something
okay next exploration
so um this is for um to generalize that
let's let's try to generalize the idea
of voronoi
um diagrams so voronoi
diagram which is voronoi mesh in
mathematica
because it produces that structure it
can maintains all the connectivity
structure that you need
but the each cell is defined basically
exactly what i said before which is
that here are the points and each
other things in this cell are points
that are closer to this point than to
any other point
so specifically i can define it like
this you know
those are the points that are closer to
to my point p i
then to any other one that's not i
okay that's not pi
and that's exactly so really
the voronoi diagram is really sort of
kind of
like um region nearest function
it's sort of a compiled form of regis
nearest function
and that was sort of how it kind of came
up right
and we can use this very symbolic
definition that i gave here
and using region plot for those
inequalities and you'll see it returns
you know it's exactly the same cell
structure
okay well region nearest and region
distance and so on they need to sort of
figure out
what what transformation what projection
function to use for each subregion
to map to the closest point in the cell
so
so in the case of voronoi diagrams that
projection function is just pick the
point in the cell
okay so it's a particularly simple
projection function
so i'm just have something here that
sort of scrapes the the values and the
conditions out of piecewise
so if i do regenerate for a bunch of
points the same points we looked at now
i get a piecewise function like this and
it says this is sort of a logic
description of that cell
and this is the nearest point let's look
at
those cells again we get back the
voronoi diagram
okay but let's but we need to
make this work for any region not just
point sets
okay so let's do one one simple sort of
extension of that is a triangle
so if we compute it in the symbolic form
we get
um you know we get the conditions for
for when some particular projector so if
i'm in the triangle
it's the point itself and here
um let's say where is this
this is for let's point one out here so
that second cell that's probably this
cell here
okay when i'm below it then i'm gonna go
to so any point here is going to project
on to that edge
edge there is what this this formula
says it's going to be
x the same x value but y is going to be
0.
so that that this structure is sort of
the
the generalized voronoi diagram for a
triangle
it gives you all the cells that you need
to to and the projectors that you need
for the different cases
now this and so you if you explore the
basic regions you'll find
all of these things derived and computed
so if i do it for tetrahedron it gets a
little bit more complicated
because i have a few more you know i
need to take into account all the points
all the edges all the faces so it breaks
down into a few more cases
and if i visualize the cells so this is
again this is like the generalized
voronoi diagram for tetrahedra
this case the one that you saw and
here you see it and if we do that for um
that is annoying okay
if we do that for a bunch of the matters
and and and you can play with it
yourself this is for um
this is for a half line this is the iso
distance
curves and these are the cells this is
the corresponding voronoi cells
this is for line segment and this is the
corresponding cells this is for a half
plane
and the corresponding paranoid cells in
3d
and this is just fun this is almost
intoxicating once you start playing with
this
um this is the triangle we saw or
polygram
parallelogram hexahedra
things in 3d
you can even do it for non-linear
primitives so
this is why this is why the disk is so
easy
the cell structure here we all know it
it's like you're in the disk or you're
outside
okay we can do that um this is for
for a disk sector this is for a lip
sector
ellipsoidal sector or these are
is for a cylinder um we get sort of one
region here
here up on top here we're going to
project on to the top
flat of the of the cylinder or or a cone
okay last exploration
so oftentimes it's really good to have a
simpler region
that approximates your region in some
sense and if you know that it's an upper
approximation or lower approximation it
you can make more firm statements
so i'm going to just show using the
tools we have to derive some
upper approximations so so let's use a
um
a cow okay we have a few of these
bounds bounding regions built in so you
have
some it's one of the properties i didn't
show but we can compute the bounding box
it's called region bounds
um gets you the bounding box we show
that as a cuboid
and this is good if we ship it by fedex
or something
okay we have other ways of of wrapping
it up
or bounding it is that i take the points
out and i can compute the convex hole
which i
saw in the beginning there so this is
kind of like shrink wrapping it
but we can get all kinds of other things
that might be useful for our computation
so here i'm going to find a ball
so in order to do that i'm going to use
our optimization function and i'm going
to try to find a good starting value
so good starting value is to just put a
ball around that
box the bounding box because then i have
something that i know is valid it's it's
too big
of a ball because it's not the minimum
volume but it's
you know it's valid right so this is
what this initial thing does here is
like attack that box
uh compute the the middle point of that
that's going to be the center
of my ball and then i compute sort of
half the diagonal as the radius for that
ball
that's going to be my initial values and
then i just want to minimize the volume
of the ball
such that every point that's in that
cow m is in the bowl
okay and fine we compute that
we get a result
which in this case is the center the
first three is the center and the last
one is the radius and here
is a balloon you know this is
our nicely packaged cow
or we can do we can save on material by
using an ellipsoid
so it's the same idea right i'm using
the same starting values
and so this gives us the
minimum volume ellipsoid instead the x
is aligned ellipsoid so it's not
can you know can be so now
we have shrink wrapped it in an
ellipsoid instead
there are lots of these okay
so that was the set of um explorations
where i wanted to use the framework and
combine them in some ways still
hopefully easy and and accessible
um so here's what we've seen you know
it's regions properties solvers
regions properties solvers okay it's the
framework and here's we break them down
and we've seen some uses of it
now what's the future so
i talked a little bit about 1002 for
this release so this support for
visualization functions that you saw me
use
it's about 10 of them that's going to be
available and documented in 1002
support for optimization is was already
there in 10.00 but
we've included now for mesh regions so
any region now works
um anything geometric searching and
distance
meaning nearest and distance and so on
for mesh based regions is
vastly improved performance wise
2d discretization has been vastly
approved application the examples have
been
greatly expanded and there are many sort
of robustness
bugs other things that that also
performance
in the future so all of what you've seen
here today will sort of improve there
will be more kinds of region there's
nothing that limits us from having a
a cad region a boundary represented with
nurbs boundary surfaces
we don't have it today but nothing
prevents us from doing that you can see
how that would just slot into the
framework
or any other kind of of of regen family
um same game thing goes for properties
there are many more properties that you
probably want
widely available and they come from
different kinds of domains
and same goes for solvers
and you'll see a lot more interaction
with the outside world
and that includes other systems but
nearby are things like 3d printing and
3d scanning to make that really
really streamlined and really simple and
whole new categories of things
and if you want to learn more um
there are the four talks here in the
conference
talks and workshops um there's also many
talks that already are using
geometry i think the talk following this
one for instance will be
and and i i know a handful of others
beyond this
that already are using it or
the thing to do here is to interact with
the team while you're here
so this is so you can identify them
adam nina peritosh
charles dylan rob ulysses
and oliver some of these you've already
seen giving talks in the ones that i saw
before
there's also plenty of other material
there is all these
these marketing pages this this overview
page for geometry is
pretty much kind of like the first part
of this talk
and and
but then they're sort of more in-depth
for basic and formula regions and
data and mesh regions and derived
regions
and then we made a special one for for
pdes
although so pde is one of these
which has been a very important driver
for the development of what we've done
in geometry and will be doing in
geometry for that matter
and but also an important contributor
because being able to do that
trivially is kind of important plenty of
guide pages
so geometric computation is the overall
sort of introduction to the thing
um that gives you that whole picture
that i've tried to communicate to you
here today
and from here you can get to everything
and that's also a basic tile on the
help viewer
now how do i delete this god
then then there are various kinds of
alternate introductions you know for
plane geometry
uh solid geometry and then you you're
going to recognize
after this talk you recognize all these
topics and you can kind of guess what it
is
the stuff here is complete and
that's all i had to say